[Music]
what's your opinion about friendship
what is a good friend according to you
friendship is something important for me
after my family my friendship is the
most important
time i can tell everything that might be
separate from others
a true friendship for me is when you can
tell them
everything and you know it's safe so
you can trust them for everything
you can trust them with secrets any
information
you can tell them private stuff personal
stuff
and always be there to listen to hear
you out
and they won't judge you they will only
support you because they love you
unconditionally
that's one word to describe a good
friendship but when there are no
expectations you love them
unconditionally
without any conditions and most people
would have
a long-lasting friendship and that's
what i believe
it's important when it comes to a real
friendship
uh sabrier what about you
for me a
friend a friend is someone who is there
for you
to help you to support you
also to listen to you
um a true friend
tells you when you're wrong even if it
hurts
because they want the best for you
you want the best for you okay yeah
that's true
the true friend does that samia
a yes is someone who is kind to you and
knows how you feel when nobody knows
and they are always by your side
in their bad times are in the good times
there are like second premier league do
you have
any good friends in your life i mean we
all do it
okay do you meet them or see them or
hear from them
often
you text with them right yes
okay okay oh very good thank you
now since we all have an idea what
friendship
is let's hear another definition of
friendship and special friendship
and good friendship uh we answered this
question how do you define a true friend
what is difference between a good friend
and a true friend
no basically we were there somewhere
we summarized these two questions just
with a different uh twist
okay now i'm gonna zoom out i guess you
can see
probably you can't see what's yeah
uh what is written there but now you can
what kind of a text is this what do you
think
i mean where can you see this is this
something you would publish in the
magazine
in an online uh it looks like an article
i think this is an article is this part
of a book
or is this something you would publish
online
meaning no it's definitely not a part of
a book but it can be a topic that you
can post in your like school magazine as
a topic or
online maybe but it's like mainly an
article what do you think the author is
we have here jason powell
we haven't read anything from the text
we don't know who it is but
i want you to guess uh what do you think
he does
is he a teacher is he somebody
i i think he's a student postgraduate
student
university student or
more like high school student high
school student okay
maybe like a high school student that
loves if he went up to college
so he's just sharing this one last
uh he wants right here his opinion
so people would be aware because because
the time when we make the most friends
out of our life and we think so high
school
you make a lot of friends but then after
you finish high school
you will only then you realize that
yeah you know
so you think this is a a newspaper
report an online article an informal
letter a literary description
you think this is the first one or a
second one
second this is something somebody post
on their social media
or their blog their website
okay now before we do anything we're
going to listen to it
and then after listening we're going to
do some answering
and some discussion unit 7 page 59
read exercise 3
read and listen to the text
is there such a thing as a true friend
by jason powell
this is a topic that's close to my heart
but i didn't really know the answer to
the question until about a year ago
first let me tell you something
you will have around 350 friends in your
lifetime
but only six of them will be your true
friends i was quite surprised when i
read about this fact
in a magazine survey the other day i
mean
if i look down the list of contacts on
my mobile
most of the names in the list are
friends names
it's the same on anyone's phone however
it made me stop and ask myself who would
i contact
if i wanted a shoulder to cry on or if i
had a genuine emergency
there were actually only a few people on
the list that i'd phone in a moment of
crisis
and i suppose it's those people that i
regard as my true
friends one person i
definitely phone is rob
i still remember when we first met last
year
i was sauntering past the sports hall in
the local leisure center
when i got a glimpse of a teenage boy in
a wheelchair
playing basketball i stopped and watched
for a while
he was about the same age as me but i
didn't think we'd have anything in
common
after all he was in a wheelchair
how wrong i was a few days later
i was lifting weights next to the same
boy in the gym
and we started chatting we got on really
well
and i suddenly realized that robbed
wheelchair didn't make him different
from me
at all he was a typical teenager like me
and he was interested in doing the same
sort of things as me
we've been really good friends ever
since
the most important thing i learned that
day is never to judge someone by what
they look like
people often treat rob differently
because of his wheelchair
but they shouldn't they should take time
to find out about the real person
one of the things i admire most about
rob is his
unselfish nature he's very good at
listening
and he doesn't ask too many questions
people like that are very generous
especially these days when everyone is
on the go
and often people can't think beyond
their own obligations and personal
concerns
i'm sometimes quite selfish so rob
is a really good example for me
so my answer to the question is there
such a thing as a true
friend is a resounding yes
they are the people who are always there
for you
they won't mind if you interrupt them in
the middle of something important
they won't mind if you call them in the
middle of the night because you need
someone to talk to
try it yourself next time otherwise
you won't know who your true friends are
okay so it was interesting
it was probably based on true story it's
very possible for this
story to be true because every day we
have
people that look or sound or
are treated differently and then
those people are the least people who
could be
your best friends and this is a very
good example
we don't choose friends based on what
they look or
their status their
rich families their rich dad the job the
dad does or mom does
etc we choose them for certain reasons
but are based
on uh features of their characters and
the qualities of
their personalities they're good
qualities that they have
now we already uh listen to the text
we're gonna try and guess these
sentences if they're true or false
hopefully you listen carefully
the writer is interested in the subject
of true friends
is this true clearly
clearly okay the writer took part in a
survey
in a magazine
no it was online right
writer read a survey in a magazine but
that he didn't take part in a survey
serbia sword unkit yeah
third one the writer has only got
friends names on his mobile phone
contact list not only not only but
most of them okay i don't think it's
true
yeah and most of the names in the
contact list are friends
but you see here uh what slightly
changes the correct answer is just a
little word here
most of the names this word makes it
false
normally what people do is summarize
this whole idea
so yes he had friends in his contact
list
but not only friends everyone in the
contact list
is his or her friends that's why most of
the names
is the detail that makes this sentence
false this is called critical thinking
no even the slightest word the slightest
detail or punctuation
may change the final answer so pay
attention to these
little details the fourth the writer
hadn't considered
who his true friends were until this
might be true
didn't considered do you think he didn't
have any idea
he had the idea but not until
then he he made sure that now i know who
my friend is because
he in the end he gives us the same
advice as he gave to himself i guess
we have to try unless we wouldn't know
who our true friends are
five the fact that rob can't walk makes
a difference when people meet him for
the first time
true for sure
it's true they are seen differently and
most of the time they're treated
differently
which is unfair so that's not something
we should do
as well no matter how uh good intentions
we have we shouldn't even
try and open these kind of conversations
i mean
ideas and words like they're gonna make
them feel uncomfortable
six the writer and rob have got a lot of
things in common
true does jason and
rob have a lot of things in common yes
it's true yeah i stated that
they're interested in the same sort of
stuff as he said and that's what
uh that's what make them click together
uh having things in common is uh one way
of
finding friends because
you talk about the same things you're
interested in the same stuff
seven the writer thinks he is less
selfish than rob
oh so false because what does he think
actually
not him sometimes he thinks he is
selfish
and he takes rob as an example yeah he
takes rob as a good example
of what he should be uh what does this
teach us actually
do you think uh examples and lessons and
teachings from the books
are important but you think having
someone
uh having somebody with the those
qualities
do you think it's easier for us to learn
our lessons
yeah learning from somebody who is
living those kind of qualities that we
want
yeah okay this is easier
and this is more believable because if
you advise me about
friendship um i don't know friendship
problems about anything you can think of
right now but
if i see you live what you preach
what you talk to me about then most
probably i'll believe you
and whatever you say it's going to sound
believable to me because you do it
you act like you say that there's also
being
and living in a convincing life so
most people learn through this kind of
approach
you learn most from the people who live
what
they say so that's what we should do as
well
we should only advise other people that
the things that we
only do so we we say what we don't
actually live
or experience we don't do we just only
want people to be perfect and we don't
take a look at ourselves
sometimes this is what happens which is
not quite fair to other people
and the last one the writer believes you
can call a true friend whenever you need
to
is this true yes because
you can call a friend whenever you need
to in the middle of the night in the
middle of a crisis in the middle of a
test
okay we or we all agree to that
now we have some questions but it's
already 10 30
and we have
uh 10 more minutes choose the best
answers the writer
and i'm gonna ask you individually to be
there
i want to make sure that you're there
and you are
active in our lessons
now first one sabria the writer read
that people will make about 350 friends
by doing a magazine survey by going to a
leisure center
during their time at school during the
whole of their life
uh i think it's d okay can you just
read your answer during the whole of
their life
so you can make you will make 350
friends approximately
during the whole of their life do you
think this is true do you agree with
this conclusion with this claim
and it does it depends on
person because someone is not friendly
so
the others are the others are so it
depends on the culture as well
uh for example german people or
british people are very difficult to
become friends with to befriend
they're difficult to befriend them but
italians and albanians
i know this is based on what other
people say this is a cultural thing
they say we're very easy to be friended
because we're very social we hug too
much we laugh
we talk out loud etcetera etcetera these
are qualities that make people
comfortable and then hey
after three minutes after two or three
sips
or coffees uh people consider your
friends
this is something debatable we're not uh
we're not here to
jump to conclusions the second one um
artioda what do you think
when the writer first saw rob he what
recognized him thought he'd be good
friends didn't think they'd get
on or he wanted to play basketball with
him
well the last one's funny what do you
think which option is
he didn't think they'd get he
you thought he didn't think they'd
get on why do you think why do you think
that
based on when he first saw him
he was in the wheelchair and he thought
that
they wouldn't have many things in common
and but it turns out they both like
the same things yeah yeah it turns out
they have a lot of stuff in common so
he kind of he kind of judged based on
his years
okay the next one we have the third
third question what what we're doing
here
is analyzing the test not every answer
is uh bluntly shown on the text
some of the answers are uh
are to be found within the lines are
understood or are taken out or taken out
of the context
okay uh third one uh can
linda answer uh yeah
what do you think the question and the
answer
really learned that you can know a
person just by
looking at them you can't know a person
just by
looking at them do you agree with this
statement linda
okay okay you know there's a
uh very interesting expression that
people
here use it i've heard it in different
places but
uh 500 scriptments my phone said yeah
yeah we use it
similar some idioms are similar in
different languages
third one um
sorry fourth one reika
uh the writer thinks that many people
these days don't have
time to think about
others don't have time to think about
others okay now can you explain this a
little bit to me what do you what do you
understand from this
so obviously you think this is true but
how according to your opinion
do people find time for others or others
business
is this something uh you know rare
in our daily lives
yes why do you think that is and
obviously you're no you're not one of
those people so
how do you do it how do you find time to
care for others
and why do you do it or you're too shy
to tell it in front of the
other classes because this is something
might
you know it might also be called
personal but yeah i just wanted to get
you talking so
so good the fifth one the writer says
that you will only know
who your true friends are in a moment of
crisis
in the middle of the night if you're in
a wheelchair or if you ask
lots of questions
in the middle of the night okay what
does this mean does this
really mean we have to call somebody in
the middle of the night and
if they pick up the phone they're good
friends and if they don't pick up the
phone they're not good friends or
what's the context of this as question
here
unseen that's that's good that's the you
forgot some
english words i don't know or this is
not your english day because some people
have separated the days of the week into
english days and albanian days that's
what i've heard so
it might be one of your albanian days
where you only speak albanian
okay and the last one the writer says
that you will only know who your true
friends are
for sake in the middle of the night
perspective
they're always there they can pick up
the phone they can answer you they can
respond
they are there and they can help you out
good so that was the last one next time
we meet we're going to
talk about the ideas understanding ideas
always based on what we
read today and the vocabulary part good
if you don't have any questions
this might be uh it for today
these expressions here that are
highlighted in purple
i think you should uh look them up on
internet
these most of them are um words
and there are some uh phrases as well
like your shoulder to cry and close to
my heart
yes so look them up on internet so you
would have
a clear picture and you wouldn't have
any unknown words when we read it next
time
okay thank you for being here i wish you
a great day
and goodbye
[Music]